في تحدي لتحذيرات المرشد الايراني بقمع
الاحتجاجات ومطالبه السلطه القضائيه
بمحاكمتكافه المشاركين في المظاهرات
الشعبيه تتواصل الاحتجاجات في اكثر من 30
مدينه و18 محافظه ايرانيه
رافقتها اضطرابات طلابيه في نحو 50 جامعه
وكليه في العاصمه الايرانيه طهران
جاءت المدن الكرديه في المقدمه وتحديدا
مدينه مهابات في اذربيجان الغربيه التي
تعرضت خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه الى هجوم مكثف
من قبل القوات الامنيه والعسكريه بالاسلحه
الثقيله وقطع الكهرباء ورغم القمع الذي
تتهم قوه الامن والقوات الخاصه والبازيد
بممارسته الا ان سكان هذه المدينه خرجوا
للشوارع منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى للمشاركه
في الاحتجاجات اما الجامعه الايرانيه
فاستجابت لدعوات الاضطراب الطلبه نظم
مسيرات احتجاجيه في 50 جامعه وكليه ومعهدا
تقريبا شملت خمس جامعات كبرى في طهران نظم
فيها اكبر تجمع احتجاج للطلاب تحديدا في
جامعه تبريز للعلوم الطبيه وجامعه بهجت في
طهران بالاضافه الى جامعه كردستان وجامعه
القدس التي شهدت اعنف هجوم من قبل القوات
الامنيه
نتج عنه اصابه عدد كبير من الطلبه بجروح
خطيره واعتقال عدد اخر منهم وقد قتل احد
طلابها ويدعى حميد رضا روحي والذي تحول
جنازته في مقبره بهجت زهره الى تجمع
احتجاج جديد سلطان العربيه